vous êtes là bonjour bonnet venez avec
moi je vais aller jouer un air de
tamboura françois enfin tu es fou sur
autant de nous et savent pas que je suis
en train de lire le journal dit mme
desroches suis très attaché en mai mais
je n'avais pas du tout pensé à tout ça
françois tu es excuse moi je ne voulais
pas te mettre en colère je te demande
pardon d'obasi d'une demande pardon je
peux plus me mettre en colère je vais
continuer à lire mon journal
à tout à l'heure casimir c'est
formidable mais il suffit que je demande
pardon pour qu'ils ne soient plus en
colère je vais essayer quelque chose
france soir oui qu'est-ce qu'il ya
casimir soir pardon pardon mais pourquoi
casimir a pour ceux ci j'ai dit que tu
me dérangeait casimir memic tu ne peux
pas te mettre en colère puisque je t'ai
demandé pardon tu sais casimir c'est
quelquefois difficile de vivre avec toi
bon eh bien je prends mon journal je
vais un peu plus loin et je vais lire
tranquillement au revoir
sabrina tient bon jour quasi mis à part
dont sabrina pourquoi mon pauvre quasi
1000 pour soucier tu deviens
complètement fou regarde tu m'as fait
tellement peur que j'ai laissé tomber
tout mais jouer j'en ai envie mais deux
ou trois je suis très fâché limites mais
tu ne peux pas accro à chiens y voyons
puissent quand je t'ai demandé pardon
alors ouah ouah
on va faire une bonne blague avec les
ennemis
c'est tout d'abord il me fait une blague
la même chose on va voir ses dribbles et
de rien sans faire de bruit une sabrina
tu nous donnes des instruments de
musique et on va faire beaucoup de bruit
dans les oreilles de casimir tableau le
tombeau ouvert vers des violeurs les
baguettes une petite musique tour tel
film et sophie caisson lui donne sa
fille voilà une trompette loi du premier
n'aura t as rien compris
voilà comme ça là comme ça
casini on te demande tous pardo
pourquoi pour ça vous exagérez
mais enfin casimir honte à demander
pardon tu ne peux plus mettre en colère
ah oui mais moi je n'avais pas compris
que c'était pour ça que vous me
demandiez pardon je suis très en colère
la gym la tête fragile
vous comprenez may hamm mais je
comprends c'est parce que j'avais fait
la même chose tout à l'heure et oui
casimir
oui j'ai pas de demander pardon pardon
pardon pardon non non il faut le penser
et non sincères non mais là j'ai
vraiment dû pour que vous vous ennuyez
tout à l'heure alors bref vraiment je
m'excuse et puis cette fois je vous
demande pardon très mais vraiment je à
oui alors je vous demande pardon cas là